au québec en matière de recyclage eh
bien on n'obtient pas la note de passage
à peine 54 % des matières recyclables
sont recyclés en réalité alors que
l'objectif du gouvernement c'est 70%
le grand responsable de cette contre
performance c'est le vert en 2010 53 %
du verre était recyclé au québec en 2015
sa peine 14% le reste est envoyé vers
les sites d'enfouissement
le problème avec le vert au québec c'est
la méthode de récupération
le verre est envoyé en vrac vers les
centres de tri les bouteilles se casse
se mélange avec d'autres matières le
vert se retrouve à être contaminée avant
il y avait une usine pour décontaminer
le vert et l'envoyer finalement au
recyclage mais elle a fermé et les
recycleurs au québec doivent faire venir
leurs matières premières des maritimes
et de l'ontario parce que d'abord les
bouteilles sont consignés et plus
faciles à récupérer parce que le verre
est plus pur
à montréal le taux de recyclage du verre
devrait s'améliorer puisque en 2019 on
prévoit ouvrir un nouveau centre de tri
avec un intérieur un système de
nettoyage du verre à la fine pointe de
la technologie
mais même si on améliore notre bilan
avec le verre on a déjà un autre
problème deux tiers de notre papier
recyclé en chine et on sait les chinois
n'en veulent plus
[Musique]